o la sal o labrit tengo un reto para ti
ya que escuché que tienes algún tipo de
poderes predictivos que eres algo así
como un mago tal vez hay algo de verdad
en eso pero una verdad limitada ja ja
quiero probarlo lo que hice fue poner en
un recipiente negro un cierto número de
canicas negras y blancas y como ya sé
que me dirás puede aprobar te que tengo
negras y blancas así que aquí está la
blanca ok
esa es la blanca no hay ningún truco por
aquí yo también soy un poco mago mago
matemático mago matemático y acá está la
negra negra así que ambas existen puedes
tocar las puedes hacer todo lo que
quieras pero no puedes ver el interior
del recipiente la rasco y les hago
cosquillas sí sí lo que quieras hacer
hay más bolas negras o blancas esa es mi
primer pregunta podrás adivinar si hay
más o menos y puedes decirme
me niego a adivinar no no no no quieres
jugar no sé sólo me has mostrado dos
canicas sólo sé que hay al menos una
blanca y una negra pero no quiero
mostrarte que hay adentro entonces qué
hacemos
puedo podemos sacar algunas puedo
hacerlo yo
qué tal qué tal si lo hago yo ya que
puede ser que conozcas las canicas o que
logres verlas y elijas al sacarlas
es decir quiero que hagamos una
selección aleatoria
negra puedo hacerlo de nuevo puedes
hacerlo pero déjame regresar la canica
perfecto eso me parece justo
y mis ojos están cerrados
y ahora tenemos una blanca
esto es fascinante en 10 intentos
sacamos 5 blancas y 5 negras así que no
apostaría mis ahorros ya que una vez más
podría ser la forma en la que las elegí
pero si tuviera que adivinar diría que
tienes un número igual de canicas
blancas y negras así que esa es tu
respuesta y la razón que calcula este ok
podemos decirlo así uno a uno por cada
canica blanca hay una negra o puede
suponer que la mitad de las canicas son
blancas y la mitad negras ahora bien
podría estar perfectamente mal pero
bueno muéstranos las canicas más las
noticias
tenemos dos negras y cuatro blancas
wow entonces la respuesta correcta es
dos blancas por cada negra la razón es 2
a 1 al principio estaba muy cerca al
principio estaba en lo correcto y pienso
que tal vez con más intentos es menos
probable que obtengas la respuesta
correcta
no no estoy en desacuerdo con eso estoy
estoy en completo desacuerdo pienso que
entre más intentos esta vez sucedió que
perdía el camino correcto sin embargo
pienso que si lo hiciera más veces
llegaría a algo cercano a la respuesta
correcta